we're gonna go to rudy rudy is in corpus
christi texas hi rudy how can we help
hey dave hey rachel um so i just wanted
to say that you've taken a call
um last week i went ahead and got laid
off from my job
when i worked in the sports industry um
and so we're
you know in the very beginning steps of
baby step two and i've got a severance
package kind of coming my way
after i'm working at the organization
for 10 plus years oh
and i do also have some 401k
kind of stashed away um the company was
matching
uh four percent for every five percent
we put in so um i know
uh things anyways i i had the money
there of my question is
what should i do um kind of leading up
the next couple months leading up to the
holidays and after
um you know sports industries not very
uh
not gonna probably bounce back you know
overnight or anything like that so
um between the sevens and my uh 401k
should i cash that out and try to pay
off some more debt to see
what where my wife should do no we're
gonna stop
everything stop your baby step two uh
you roll your 401 401k of the direct
transfer rollover into another ira
with a smart vester pro and you don't
touch that unless it's to avoid
bankruptcy or foreclosure
you don't pay off any debt you pile up
cash as high as you can pile it until
you get the other side of the storm
then you push play again on your
that snowball and you start off once
you're settled again
and so what did you do for the sports
organization
um i had many roles lately over the last
five years i was the
retail manager there so okay so you have
that those skills are transferable
outside of sports
you don't have to wait for sports to
kick back off
no pun intended yeah uh yeah 100
um i've got a couple uh i just finished
my resume today actually i'm sending off
a couple
job applications today um you know
obviously with the retail industry uh
just
kind of period the economy is just a
little little
you know but there are places that are
booming i mean it's just segments of the
economy they're nuanced
i mean if you worked in a plexiglass
store things would be going good for you
because everybody's putting up a black
glass shield over everything for god's
sakes
so um you know that kind of stuff right
so there's stuff that's
boat business and atv and motorcycle
business is booming
uh car business is booming you know real
estate business is booming so there's
all kinds of things you can move towards
and if you get land something very
quickly all that severance becomes a
signing bonus
and you'll be in a great position so i'm
sorry you're going through this
especially at this time of year but just
stop
everything pile up cash that's simple